welcome to this video playing misty from
Finland let's see what we get let's play
kings in units of an entertaining and
Bishop e3 good line okay back when I
played the Kingston you non regular
basis I had to employ them some other
variation play the E takes d4 I really
have to have no idea about this but
something something like this is there
is a playable line pretty sure about
that and now G for this is one one
possibility and now now we're back into
something that I at least believed to
have seen before Bishop age 6 s son the
key idea for black I think this is
probably my next month regardless of
what he is playing even if I stock up on
here on on f6 doesn't really matter the
questions should i claim should i play
move like see 5 or shouldn't I okay
let's do this first if he takes f6 then
I have Bishop g5 this should be at least
some compensation okay
he's just he's just taking it I thought
this would be compensation and which
doesn't mean he shouldn't take or
something it's just I hope that this is
enough I have a good Bishop now or in
this in this case on this pressure on
the F file and we just gives her the
pawn immediately back yeah why not
actually let's just grab it Queen where
2g 3m can go to f4 yeah of course the H
file I must be a I must be cautious
Queen f8 is a move that I would like to
play but there's a night to be five
quite an annoying response prin g3 h4
hmm interesting
hmm don't really know I don't think I'm
in bad shape don't think so but it's
it's not quite not easy not easy to play
23 I'm stupid Queenie three you always
see them right after you move it after
that the lighter doesn't have a square
yeah now I need to play go into a crook
f4 and I could have could have done that
could have done that earlier ah stupid
now okay I hope it's not immediately
young although I anything okay Queen H
foursome is the problem one problem of
course it's it's not it's not winning
immediately
tweenage form okay covering h8 so Queen
h4 at least it's not a mate and I rook a
civil son was really stupid all those
pieces that they don't belong where they
are now it's not clear that it is so so
terrible but I mean he cannot i think
immediately refuted this is a raised the
Rockies it's not bad on air for I mean
even if it is attacked with with the
night I can can easily um think about
sacrificing the exchange no no Knight f6
coming some possibility maybe I'm even
in good shape here why am I getting too
optimistic as usual always been an
optimistic player
I mean in the long run I'm in good shape
down I've got a good Bishop he's got a
bad bishop only to at least it's
potentially bad it's not done with the
space advantage this bad bad bishop
problem is not so serious I don't want
to grab horns I want to get my stuff
coordinated Knight f6 cells Queen g6
yeah there we can you can have the
exchange if you want got 95 coming and
stuff like that
the position is is very closed after
that and the night only 5 is enough
compensation for an exchange easily now
even here maybe you can play c5 now
takes takes
hmm yeah he's got Bishop Bishop to c4
coming this was very strong actually
yeah taking on c6 and c5 was strong
yeah this is basically lost now you can
grab the exchange now for a little
compensation or no compensation can nap
at least if I get 225 it so then there
is something if I take him time 45 not g
6 35 maybe
this is with tempo shouldn't exchange
check
lock it down to two seconds this is why
I like increment blitz if they play
complete nonsense you can punish it at
the end but okay it's a it does very bad
technical claim but ok I was completely
completely completely a loss of course
of course this is this is just giving
away the game in some way yeah okay yeah
with this was strong you played this
very nicely taking so c5 was bad young I
didn't I didn't appreciate this at all
to see five it's a rather typical but
okay you cannot see everything in and
then blitz yeah I can I can play all
kinds of moves I can play a rupee 8 a-6
whatever he can always take but this is
good compensation it's funny the
computer actually wants to play Queen g7
offering a queen trade you have enough
in this in this position even even if
the queen is traded I am what yeah let's
just just briefly look at this here 95
and I don't have six and he has got
nothing he can not infiltrate on the
edge file and in the long run it's very
difficult to keep you falling g4 and if
I get one of those pawns I'm better I'm
actually preferring black here mrs. this
position computers on 000 but I think
it's much easier to be black here he
didn't take of course he saw that the a
c5 was bad my idea was c5 was in the
long run prepare a 6b five but it's just
mistimed because he can take and play c5
after which i'm just crumbling and at
the end of he butchered up the same game
a bit but ok he was sure to win on time
this is why increment is such a good
thing you can never really rely on just
ok let's play some nonsense i will know
in time anyway this sounds not not on
there as i see is still struggling
struggling a bit to introduce that for
auto faring they intended to i'm not
quite sure why they haven't introduced
it yet thanks for watching